as you guys know we've been giving the
m1 macbooks a lot of attention recently
especially with all the leaks and rumors
about totally redesigned
14 and 16 inch macbook pros coming later
this year
with the new 12 core and 1x ship that
we're expecting
but as far as the mac mini we haven't
really been showing it that much love
recently
so in this video i'm going to discuss my
thoughts on the m1 model
and how it stands up to other desktop
computers
and yes i'm going to talk about the m1x
mac mini but first i want to start off
with my experience with the m1 mac mini
over the past couple of months
and why it's already a huge deal even
without the m1x chat
as many of you know apple's m1 mac mini
is priced at only 699
on their website or an even lower 649
on amazon at the current sale price if
you use the link down below
which is an absolutely great deal for a
brand new m1 mac
the model that we purchased was actually
the 899
version since we loaded it with 16 gigs
of unified memory
the reason we bought that model is
because we wanted to put it up against a
bunch of high-end
intel macs to see just how good the new
apple silicon m1 chip really is
and spoiler alert it totally blew us
away we compared it to everything from
our 12
core 15 000 mac pro a 2500
8 core 5k imac and a fully loaded
intel i7 mac mini both with and without
a 5700 xt egbu so let's go through some
of the performance results that we got
starting off with single core
performance using geekbench 5
the m1 mac mini literally beats out
every previous mac
ever made due to the new super efficient
m1 chip
which uses a totally different
architecture compared to the other
macs now getting into multi-core this is
where the m1 mac mini falls behind
because it's a pretty low end chip only
having four high performance cores
but it still beats out the intel mac
mini by around 32
so that's pretty impressive considering
the price difference
all of that was just raw benchmark
performance
so now let's get into what actually
matters the cenobench r23 cpu stress
test
here the intel max all get a nice boost
compared to the m1 mac mini
but thankfully it still outperforms the
intel model
and one important difference is that the
fans on the m1
were almost whisper silent while the
intel mac mini's fans
were blaring at the end of the test now
moving on to graphics performance
this is where it gets very interesting
in this chart
every single mac that beats the m1 is
using a dedicated graphics card
while both mac minis by themselves use
graphics chips that are integrated
inside of the main chip itself
and as you can see the m1's integrated
graphics is over four times as fast
this is a really big deal for the m1 mac
mini because it finally gets decent
graphics performance
without requiring a dedicated gpu and
this is also what's going to make the
future
m1x model so incredibly good but more on
that in just a minute now moving on to
our max tech
xcode programming test the m1 mac mini
somehow beats
every single mac including the 15 000
mac pro which we didn't think was
possible
but it goes to show just how focused
apple was
on optimizing their software for the new
chip architecture
now let's get into another common task
photo editing with lightroom classic
and by the way this app hasn't yet been
updated for apple silicon
so the m1 had to run it using rosetta 2
translation
here the m1 wasn't that far behind the
imac
which is really impressive considering
that it's practically one third of the
price
and the mac pro destroys all of them
because it had 192 gigs
of 6 channel ram which matters a lot for
photo editing
now getting into video editing this is
where graphics really comes in with a
standard
4k h.264 export as our first test
and surprisingly the m1 performs
incredibly well
finishing four times faster than the
intel mac mini
and even beating the egpu and it was
only 34 seconds slower than the mac pro
that's because the main limitation when
exporting this type of footage
is actually the hardware accelerators
and the m1 mac
basically has the latest and fastest
ones out there
and for that same exact reason the m1 is
able to export
10 bit 42 hevc footage from a canon r5
camera in only three minutes
completely destroying every single intel
mac
and in the final video editing test
exporting a 5 minute 4.5
k redraw clip most of the macs beat the
m1 mac mini
because neither of them have hardware
acceleration
for red raw footage so they all rely
mostly on graphics performance
but at least the m1 is over three times
faster than the intel mac mini so with
all of those tests out of the way
you can see that the 16 gig m1 mac mini
for only 900
is an incredibly good value compared to
the other macs
even being able to outperform the 15 000
mac pro
in a couple of the tests which is
mind-blowing but unfortunately
there are a couple of downsides like
only having two thunderbolt ports on the
back
and only supporting two displays but
thankfully
the m1x mac mini is gonna fix all of
that
so now let's finally get into that now
if you're wondering why i'm so
confident that we'll be seeing an m1x
mac mini
i have a couple of different reasons
first off there actually
aren't any leaks and rumors about an m1x
model
just some speculation and a whole lot of
common sense
and putting puzzle pieces together so
let me explain
way back before the m1 max were released
we basically had
zero leaks and rumors about apple
releasing an
m1 mac mini alongside the macbooks but
it happened and this time with the
expected m1x model
there are once again no rumors but
check out how all these puzzle pieces
come together now i don't know if you
knew this
but when the m1 macbook pro came out
last year
it only replaced the base 1300 model
apple is actually still selling the
intel based
1800 model and if you're wondering why
there are two main reasons
number one is that apple wants to give
people options during this transition
so if someone doesn't want to switch to
apple silicon just yet
they can get the intel chip instead
reason number two is because the m1
macbook pro model
has only two ports and only supports one
external display while the more
expensive intel model
has four ports and supports two external
displays
now i personally believe that the new
redesigned 14-inch macbook pro
with the m1x chip is only gonna replace
the current eighteen hundred dollar
intel model
and of course that is gonna have four
ports
the 1300 base macbook pro model is gonna
stay
unchanged sticking to the m1 chip until
further notice
now here is where it gets extremely
convincing
for the m1x mac mini just like the
macbook pro
the mac mini currently has a less
expensive base model
with the m1 chip and a more expensive
intel based model now the one thing that
you need to realize
is that apple will 100 percent get rid
of this
intel model because we know they're
gonna fully transition
over to apple silicon chips no matter
what and apple isn't just gonna drop the
intel mac mini and leave it at that
they're gonna replace it with a new
apple silicon model
and here is how i know that ever since
2018
the intel mac minis have all come with
four thunderbolt 3 ports even the base
model now what's weird about the current
base model m1 mac mini is that it's the
only model in years
to only come with two of these
thunderbolt supporting ports
which is definitely limiting for a lot
of people
and it's probably due to a limitation
with the m1 chip
because of that reason alone i believe
that apple
absolutely must release a new mac mini
model
with four ports to replace the current
intel model
just like we're expecting apple to do
with the macbook pros
and knowing apple if they do this
they're probably gonna do it
all at once so i personally expect the
m1x mac mini
to get released alongside the m1x
macbook pros
this would make a whole lot of sense
because when apple first unveiled
the m1 chip they put it into three
different macs all at the same time
so if apple unveils the m1x chip they'll
likely take the opportunity
to put it into every mac that they're
planning to put it into
all at the same time and that is why i
believe
the m1x mac mini is coming and as far as
the release date
i initially thought it would be coming
this summer but we recently got some
very bad news
both michiko and nikkei asia reported
that apple has delayed the mass
production
of the 14 and 16 inch macbook pro models
from may or june
to some time after july because of this
it's looking like these macbook pros and
probably the m1x mac mini
will be released sometime this fall
probably in
november since that's when the m1 max
were released
now with that said i want to finally get
into the m1x chip and why it's gonna be
completely groundbreaking i believe it's
gonna come with a 12 core cpu
and a 16 core integrated gpu which is
basically going to be the perfect chip
for the mac mini
since there really isn't that much room
for a dedicated graphics chip
and if you're wondering how it's going
to perform we actually estimated the
performance of the m1x
in another video so let's revisit those
performance charts
and see how it's going to compare to
those other macs single core performance
is gonna stay roughly the same
because the m1x will simply have four
more of the exact same performance cores
so no big difference there now for
multi-core this is where it's gonna get
real
with the m1x actually estimated to
outperform
the 12 core mac pro which is incredible
moving on to cinebench r23 this is the
most impressive part
the m1x should just barely beat out the
mac pro
which i don't think anybody was
expecting and finally
getting into graphics performance this
is incredible
because the m1x is almost 10 times more
powerful
than the current best intel mac mini and
it should even beat out the imac as well
so with all of that said i think there's
a pretty good chance that we'll be
seeing
a high-end m1x mac mini coming sometime
this fall
probably in november but since we
haven't
actually heard any rumors or seen any
leaks
there's also the chance that apple could
hold off for another year
if they really wanted to but i
personally think that it's coming this
year
so there you guys go hopefully you
enjoyed this video and if you disagree
with my speculation go ahead and comment
down below
but if you enjoyed it tap the like
button and click the circle above to
subscribe for more videos like this one
check out one of those two videos thanks
for watching and we'll see you in
the next one
[Music]